The joe rogan experience.
Did you hear about the new electric,
uh,
our age of a cow tipping that's going on in San Francisco and stuff like that.
People are flipping those little baby electric small cars and it's called smart
smart card tipping or something.
Yeah.
Fuck wow.
Imagine if you went outside and you,
you're a girl and you weigh a hundred pounds.
That's a dick move past.
What was it?
Dick move.
I also think I,
so I grew up in the suburbs.
I did not see a lot of cows,
I guess from time to time,
but like can you actually tip a cow a no.
Yes.
Yes you can.
There's a huge no,
no,
we've done it.
Just wants you to save it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
We did.
Columbus,
Ohio.
Me and my friends did it twice.
You've done it right?
Was it like a calf?
Was it like one of those calves to just so what happens isn't that when the cows
and the cows are in the fields,
they pretty much locked their legs and sleep,
standing up a lot.
That's how I sleep.
And so you just go next to him and push them and they usually just fall to
heavy.
No,
they,
they just tip right over hyping cow tipping site.
This was stuff that suburban kids know,
like,
or that like,
it's an urban lore because none of us ever hung out with cows.
If you ever want to go cow tipping,
I'll take it.
They would really like that,
but no,
they don't like it.
I wouldn't like it.
Did you really go cow tipping Brian twice?
Yeah.
Twice.
Can you find a new one using video
or believe it?
Yeah,
me and two of my friends.
Okay.
And I want it to be one of those,
remember those night vision like the Paris Hilton videos.
I want it to be one of those night vision videos of the cow tipping over.
All right.
Do you have a,
um,
an Instagram?
I do.
It's,
it's my name.
Just add Alexis Ohanian or neon.
Okay.
That's another thing that's annoying about these things is that they insist on
trying to change what you wrote there.
Like my creative,
the ethnic,
uh,
yeah.
They're not gonna take it personally.
They're their auto correct is like really aggressive.
He's Cather and goofy.
They're awake.
Yeah.
Well then good luck.
They're going to kill you.
I see.
No,
and I was tempted to look at these videos before you put them online,
Bro.
Seriously find something real.
Yeah,
you can do that.
I'll just go right.
Yeah,
yeah.
I Dunno.
I don't know.
I want him some show.
He might have thought he would count it on mushrooms.
Tripled his balls off to we tip cat cows,
but we never left the house,
man.
What are you talking about?
We were in the field.
You don't remember.
I was there.
I was tipping cows.
Yeah,
I bet.
If we Snopes tipping cows,
let's Snopes Snopes,
count it back.
I should have brought my laptop also.
Side Note.
Uh,
and I've,
I've enjoyed your podcast died.
I love how I love the real time with the laptops.
Uh,
I wish,
I wish every show basically had someone in real time just calling out shit.
Here we go.
Ready?
All right,
let's get this out of the way.
Cow,
at least as popularly imagined,
does not exist.
Drunk men do not on any regular basis sneaking in cow pastures and put a hard
shoulder to a cow taking a standing snooze,
dus tipping the poor animal over while in the history of the world,
there have surely been a few unlucky cow shoved there side by boozed up morons.
We feel confident in saying that this happens at a rate roughly equivalent to
the Chicago cubs winning the world series and that,
okay,
this is um,
got Snopes
cows.
Cows like sit down in like on their legs and just sit there and you can go right
up to him and tip them right over.
This is from modern farmer.com.
Well,
I'm convinced article on cow tipping.
I've subscribed modern farmer for a decade now and I,
they have never led me astray.
Youtube,
the largest clearinghouse of human stupidity the world has ever known,
right?
You can watch hours of kids taking the cinnamon challenge.
Teens jumping off route two rooftops on the trampolines and the explosive
results of fireworks set off indoors fails to deliver one single actual cow
tipping video.
All right,
well,
we did it as a kid.
The one exception is a Russian dash cam video,
which shows a semi truck full of cattle overturning.
That's really good.
You need to watch it shaking themselves off and walking away.
How's not giving a fuck?
Yeah.
Wow.
This is a spectacular dash.
So this uh,
this article is calling bullshit on your prime.
When I was younger,
we would go to these farms in planes,
plain city,
Ohio and they would have tons of cows and we would break into the cows,
smoked weed and there'd be cows that will be end into the cows.
No break into the fence.
And there would be cows that would sit there like on there like perched up like
on there like legs.
Like it's just sitting there sleeping would come over and just push him right
over.
I don't know if that's the cow tipping that you've heard everybody doing like
people saying that the cows tip over.
But that's what we used to do cause that's what we thought you were supposed to
do.
I don't understand what you just said.
This cows are standing up right?
Cause they stand up when they sleep,
right?
No,
not all the time there.
There's cows like Nathan here.
I'll show you.
Okay.
I thought cal was always stood out.
Horses always stand up.
Right.
Uh,
I have no idea.
I'm going to my guts telling me horses are the ones.
Yeah.
Horses I think always stand up,
right?
Yeah.
And if they're down,
they're hurt.
We have the Google.
Yeah.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm really Shantel.
This cow tipping.
Sorry.
We get the Internet disagrees with you.
Oh,
look at that.
That's a
brown cow.
How rolling the cat would be like that.
And he would just push it.
Yeah.
But there'd be tons of cows and it'll be night at timing would be drunk.
And that's what we used to do it.
I don't know.
That seems to be cow tipping.
Yeah.
Technically that's cow tipping.
They're just lying down cows.
So you're going to send the email to Snopes saying,
well actually you're wrong.
Well,
I have a feeling the problem with calling bullshit.
If you didn't grow up in that environment,
you might truly believe that it is bullshit.
But then at the guy like Brian actually grew up there and actually pushed over
some,
can we take this to
your fan base?
They would sit like this and then you're just like [inaudible] go over there and
just push them over and they would roll over and wake up and freak out and it
would be scary.
And you'd would run away that now cow tipping.
What I think they're saying is not true is actually tipping over a cal.
It's like completely standing up.
Maybe.
Well maybe that's what people have in their head,
but what it really is is what you're talking
the cal rolling.
That's when we did it.
We just did,
cause we heard people did it and then we were like,
let's do it.
There's tons of cows here.
Brian redband move.
People are doing it.
And I'm like,
well this show alive.
Fuck it.
So then cow tipping is real.
I guess if I would say
it depends it well yeah it coul rolling.
I'm gonna call it cal rolling.
Roll
cow tipping as an account standing up and you pushing it over.
That doesn't exist.
But that's probably not what cow tipping ever was unless they do sleep.
Standing up the couch,
sleep standing up.
Okay,
we need to call me tons of pictures of cows doing exactly how.
Yeah,
but did they also sleep standing up,
I should say.
Let me just say how much I appreciate you guys get into the bottom of this.
We need to worst case.
How far are we from some cows?
Oh,
not that far.
We can get to 100 an hour.
Okay.
Does it count?
Sleep standing?
Common misconception that cows don't lie down.
Why cows may doze off for a few minutes at a time while standing up.
They typically lie down to sleep or simply to rest.
Okay,
I'm calling bullshit on the people calling bullshit.
I think Brian's right.
I think Brian is right.
He went cow tipping and that's how you really count because what everybody says
is the cows are sleeping and you go up and push him.
Well,
obviously if that's not true,
if they only take a little nap standing up and usually they sleep lying down,
then their whole premise sucks because they don't understand what cow tipping
is.
Calex hipping starts from the knees,
like Jujitsu class.
Like if you take wrestling class,
you start standing up for the most part,
a room full of 50 dudes trying to double leg each other.
That shit gets really dangerous.
So jujitsu classes,
I'll start from the knees.
So real cow tipping like the idea of it doesn't exist because that's like
wrestling style.
Everybody starts from their feet.
But jujitsu style when you're already on the ground,
that's real.
This is great.
Now whenever I drive past a bunch of cows will be thinking about Jujitsu.
I just what I do,
that's the vision.
That's my gift.
You should,
um,
you should totally
no snuff to go fuck themselves.
The craziest thing is that modern farmer incorporate or whatever it is,
how scary it was.
I just remembered it now because I'd be scared I wouldn't go that way.
I'm not going over there.
That man we did,
I remember twice,
but we only remembers twice.
First Time scared the fuck out of you and then you're like listen,
I can do better.
And the reason why it's because one of the,
we used to hang out with this bridge where we would drink and under age and it
was just like everyone would go to this bridge in the middle of nowhere and
there was all these farms around it and that's why we'd go there cause there was
no police,
there's no one could even know you were there.
You see you can have bonfires and all this shit like that sit after he got
wasted,
everyone kind of just move,
laid around in all the fields and one of the fields,
his cows,
and it was pitch black because it was in the middle of the country.
So it was just stars and you see shadows of cows and so you would like sneak up
going up to these cows.
You didn't have cell phones for lights or anything like that.
So it was literally just lighters and Shit and you just go up and just push it
real fast.
And then we'll go and you'd just run away and it was the scariest shit ever.
Wow.
And you'd be stoked.
Did you ever find mushrooms on those cow patties?
Yeah,
but back then you just didn't think about that.
Like I didn't get into mushrooms too.
I was in college,
Dunkin went to school in Asheville,
North Carolina and when I went up there I understand Dunkin so much more after
visiting Asheville cause it's just a hippie Mecca and they were getting,
there's apparently the mushroom flora or whatever it is.
The spores are so healthy up there because it rains a lot and there's so many of
them that they had to start giving the cows some sort of an antifungal diet to
kill the mushrooms because so many core harvesting meanwhile probably makes the
kids sick.
Cause a few mushrooms probably grow on that.
Some poor poisoned psilocybin when you want to talk about missing the fucking
point right.
Poisoning cow shit.
So that the most beautiful thing that God ever created can't grow there.
You fucking dummies.
But he said that they would constantly go there and just pluck them off and just
eat them.
They were everywhere and just trip balls.
The whole town is so psychedelic,
like partially because of that.
The whole town is like Asheville,
North Carolina.
Is it trippy fucking place?
I feel like I need to visit now.
You got to visit.
It's awesome.
It's really cool.
Everybody's walking around like they have a main area where like bars and
restaurants are and he would just walking around like everybody's walking around
and it's like a small town that exists in a giant world,
but they're modern.
Since I fucked up,
I shouldn't have told you guys about it up.
Now we're going to go a road.
Asheville,
they the,
but I kind of understand Dunkin way more now after going to this town.
It's like,
oh,
I see.
Like you,
you were spawned in one of the most awesome environments on earth.
Like this place is fucking sweet.
What?
What did they call it
when they went out on an expedition?
I wonder,
do you want to go like candy harvesting?
Yeah.
Some kind of thing
that's,
it's so dangerous though,
because I remember even as a kid just going up and eating berries cause I was
like,
oh look berries.
I would just start kicking fairies.
Wow.
You know?
And then like you find out something with us kids a hundred years ago,
you would never survive.
There's no way you would have been dead before you were fire.
Yeah.
But anyways,
that honeysuckle shit like I used to eat out a lot of plant because there's
nothing to do.
So you look,
what's that purple stuff for you?
Pull it out.
Just suck on it has nothing to do.
Yeah.
So we just eat grass.
I would eat a few things.
You know what I found out that tastes good actually is dandy lions.
Like Danny Lyon,
Greens make salads at a Dandelion Greens.
Grandmother used to make
them and I went over the house once and she had this Dandy Lion Salad.
I was like,
what is that in the garden dandy lines.
And they were like,
it's really good for you.
It's edible to my aunt,
my uncle telling me it was good for me.
I think is what convinced me,
but then I found out that it's like a common vegetable that a lot of people eat
to meet.
T am I crazy?
You make tea out of it.
I believe you can.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's actually good.
Like as a salad.
It's a good tasting green and pretty fucking good for you to,
hmm.
What's not to like,
I don't know how we got on sandy line business.
Don't know how we got us to the dentist.
We've covered a lot of grants on this Yam and ECO friendly.
It makes the world go round.
My friend.